so one of the um 2022 races that we're
following more and more closely is that
of the texas gubernatorial uh race we
believe that uh beto o'rourke is going
to be entering as a democratic
challenger against the incumbent
republican governor greg abbott greg
abbott has been an absolute disaster for
the state of texas he has been
disgusting along with his lieutenant
governor dan patrick since day one of
the pandemic the infamous grandma's
willing to die for the economy incident
of course as you might remember greg
abbott has been absolutely horrible on
energy texas of course with this big boy
libertarian independent energy grid
which has failed them in the winter and
it's failed them in the summer and it's
just a disaster for texas and then now
of course recently with texas seeing
covid run rampant during the delta spike
this has fortunately really hurt the
approval ratings of greg abbott and we
have additional new data about this more
texas voters now believe that greg
abbott does not deserve re-election and
of course they are completely correct
more texas voters believe greg abbott
does not deserve to be re-elected
according to a poll released yesterday
tuesday the survey was conducted by
quinnipiac university finds that 51
percent of registered voters in texas
believe abbott doesn't deserve
re-election compared with 42 percent who
say he does deserve a third term these
are
disastrous numbers for an incumbent
republican texas governor
and i love it
the opposition to abbott's reelection is
up from june a different quinnipiac poll
in june found 46 percent said reelect
and 48 percent said no
now it's only 42 percent say re-elect 51
say no basically like a four-point slide
in the direction of bad i should say
from the standpoint of negative uh the
most recent poll also found only 44
percent of texans approve of the way
abbott is handling his job as governor
47 now disapprove
this is the first time since quinnipiac
started polling texas that abbott's
approval rating is below disapproval
referred to as being under water
this is absolutely fantastic now most
republicans still support abbott 83 of
republicans approve
only 12 percent disapprove
uh as far as independents go 43 percent
approve
only six percent of democrats approve in
texas now just as an example okay
of how absolutely
horrible this guy is
this was um over the weekend on fox news
chris wallace really grilling greg
abbott over his claim that listen we
don't have to worry about the abortion
law the dystopian abortion law that we
passed
restricting the
ability
of women who have been raped from
obtaining abortions we don't have to
worry about that because we're going to
eliminate rapists
ban the virus right i mean just make
murder illegal solve the problem okay
let's listen
is it
reasonable to say to somebody who is the
victim of rape and might not understand
that they are
pregnant uh you know until six weeks
well don't worry about it because we're
going to eliminate rape
as a problem
it doesn't make sense no but let's see
what he says
well there's multiple things i have to
say in answer to this but the first
thing obviously uh is that survivors of
sexual assault
they deserve support care and compassion
now it's funny how he says obviously
much of the republican party doesn't
make it obvious actually uh and texas is
stepping up to make sure that we provide
that by uh signing a law and creating in
the governor's office uh a sexual
assault survivors
cessual task force uh but separately
from that chris i got to point out uh
about the ways that i have fought to uh
go uh uh to arrest and apprehend and uh
try to eliminate rape but i sought the
death penalty but governor governor
governor excuse me because we are
running out of time there were more than
15 000 rapes in 2019
when you were governor yeah apparently
just you know uh ending rape
uh by threatening people with really
strict punishments you know
he he wanted the death penalty for
rapists we really continue to lack
evidence that the death penalty is
really a deterrent
um
we've studied that for a very very long
time
uh but you know we're gonna eliminate
rape is kind of like ban coronavirus and
just be done with it it doesn't make any
sense and then of course meanwhile uh
the latest is
texas has this disaster with kovid texas
has this disaster with energy
and what is abbott doing abbott is
launching voter fraud audits
from the 2020 election
bowing to trump's pressure vanity fair
reporting
greg abbott
is suddenly bending over backward to
find 2020 election fraud
abbott's office says it has been
reviewing votes
in certain texas counties for months
but others say the mad dash only started
after donald trump demanded an audit
greg abbott
is going to be
pushing for auditing multiple count
auditing recounting who even knows what
these things mean at this point in time
four counties in texas
trump won texas there is no point we
talked about this on the bonus show
yesterday there is no point to do this
whatsoever
texas is so poorly served greg abbott
lieutenant governor dan patrick remember
the cancun cruise fiasco
it would bring me no greater pleasure
than to see greg abbott just absolutely
crushed
in 2022
and beto o'rourke could be the guy to do
it i don't know i mean uh coming off of
a loss is never
doesn't put you in a particularly strong
position last week one of our live
callers asked is beto really the right
guy to face off against abbott given
that he lost his last race i don't know
the answer to that
um but we have time
listen matthew mcconaughey matthew
mcconaughey
depending on your preference better or
better or work whatever pronunciations
you you have for these folks um they
would all be better than greg abbott for
sure and we're going to follow this race
very very closely
one of our sponsors is magic spoon
breakfast cereal sweet and tasty like
the cereals i loved as a kid but without
the sugar or the carbs every serving of
magic spoon has zero grams of sugar only
four net carbs 140 calories and packed
with 13 grams of protein perfect if
you're doing keto perfect if you're
doing low carb
great if you're just trying to reduce
your excess sugar intake and because
it's packed with protein it's great
before or after a workout magic spoon
flavors include cocoa fruity frosted
peanut butter blueberry and cinnamon
they're bringing back cookies and cream
they're bringing back maple waffle you
can build your own variety box and try
them all magic spoon is so confident in
the product if you don't love it as much
as i do they will refund your money no
questions asked go to magicspoon.com
pacman the link is underneath this video
and you'll get five dollars off when you
use the promo code pacman at checkout